welcome to the launch of our course on
shaping the future of work together over
the next seven weeks we'll explore how
to expand the number of good jobs career
opportunities and workplaces that help
us all realize our dreams our
aspirations we have for work for our
family lives and for building
sustainable successful enterprises and
for our societies but before we talk
about that let's talk about some of the
difficulties we've experienced in the
last week or so I want to begin with a
statement of solidary for our colleagues
in Europe and in Asia and like light of
the terrible tragedies that have
occurred in Brussels and in Pakistan
today we are all sharing our concern
that there have been over the past 18
months 75 bombings in over 20 countries
killing over 1,300 people we think about
the grief and the pain that so many
nationalities and religions and people
of different cultures all over the world
have been experiencing and we are with
them together my fellow course team
members here at MIT and I feel
profoundly sad and yet more acts of
violence we condemn them we we are
committed to addressing the causes of
violence in our societies and in our
workplaces and to doing everything we
can to help resolve these differences
before they'd evolve into terrorism
above all this course rests on the
principle of respect for diversity in
our world in our workplaces we had
planned to show a bit later in the
course a 20 minute video interview with
mary rowe one of the world's leaders in
managing diversity and workplace
conflicts Mary outlines the ways that we
can address these tensions and the anger
that they they show in our society and
that sometimes do spill over to our
places of work but given the events in
Europe and Asia and other parts of the
world we'll post that interview this
week so we can start discussing these
issues now so we invite you to watch
Mary's interview and use it in the
discussion forum to comment on how
issues of diversity inclusion and the
management of inequities can be
addressed in your workplace and in your
job experiences we can design a better
future as we help each other shape this
aspect of our workplaces in a positive
way I invite you also to get started by
sampling the rich away array of other
videos that we have posted this week we
have welcoming comments from national
and internationally renowned leaders
from all over the world the US Secretary
of Labor Tom Perez the director-general
of the International Labour Organization
guy Ryder the secretary-treasurer of
America's largest union federation Liz
Schuler and our course teams human
resource management expert Lee dire we
include this diversity of voices to show
how all of these communities need to
work together to shape the future of
work for you and for all the parties
that have a stake in it and don't miss
our three minute animated video
summarizing three thousand years of the
history of work I think you will enjoy
it then we move on to other videos and
readings that discuss the challenges and
exciting opportunities innovations
occurring in our workplaces today these
set the stage for a much much more
in-depth conversation about these issues
in the weeks ahead we also note in your
discussion forum that you already
started that some of you are concerned
about how the issues of jobs in the
future of work are being discussed in
the presidential campaign in the United
States some of you have lamented that
yes they talk about jobs but don't have
a vision for the future of work well
maybe it's our job to bring our voices
into these conversations as we will try
to do and really lay out a vision for
what work could be what the real needs
of workers are what the real needs of
businesses are today so maybe that we
can add our voices to this discussion so
welcome join us look forward to having
you engage with us and helping to see if
we can use our collective efforts to
shape the future of work